uh hello New York it's so good to be
back here in person thank you on for
that introduction and thank you all for
joining me here uh for this talk today
so my name is Shel Woody I am a
supervisor of data science uh machine
learning at the top Institute in Ottawa
uh Ontario Canada
uh that Institute is a
fundamental uh resources to do we're
owned by the Canadian government and we
do research in areas of things
associated with cryptography things
associated with data science and so
forth
but my area of course is on data
scientific side of the house and that's
what we've been talking today
our mission is to try and make
improvements to fundamental algorithms
of data science
um things like when I say fundamental
algorithms I mean things like
unsupervised learning uh dementia
reductions or clustering or uh or uh
nearest neighbor things like that
algorithms that you're going to use
every day for the type of work that we
do if you're familiar with algorithms
like umap that was developed by my
colleagues uh
and popularized as well we also do
research into uh relational data graph
type algorithms things like graph
clustering graph partitioning
ensembled models and so forth but the
thing I'm going to talk to you about
today is neither of those the thing I
want to talk to you about today is
reproducibility
um
so today's a bit of a war story time all
right it's uh it's a talk that's
motivated by in fact that's very room uh
is a talk that was uh that is sort of a
follow-on to a talk I gave a few years
ago at high data at New York City 2018.
in this very spot
um I wanted to give you another update
because clearly we're all there right
uh on how things have been going in the
various lessons that we have learned
um since we started but if you'll deal
with me for a second before we get there
I'd like to take a little detour
through
philosophy
and I like to talk about xeno's Paradox
so quick show of hands who this room is
familiar with Zero's paradox
that's good for those of you who are not
I'm going to try to explain it the
traditional way to explain it is kind of
weather set up like this you've got
somebody a little Banksy guy here uh
trying to throw something I'd say that
tree you're throwing a bouquet of
flowers seems like a full air in the
butt he's gonna try it anyway now xeno's
Paradox says that this can never happen
he can never hit that tree with that
bouquet of flowers I mean why do you
certainly will be a flower
but two xenos paradox says the reason he
can't hit that tree is before that
bouquet of flowers flies all the way
through the air all the way hits that
tree it's cycle halfway
it's halfway it's got to make it halfway
through the second half and then it's
going to make halfway to the halfway
that's left there again and halfway to
halfway to the halfway to the halfway at
right and Zero's problem with this is
you know didn't like Infinities Xeno
said it can never get there because it's
always got to go halfway into somewhere
else and there's no way out for this
that's pretty much the standard setup I
don't like that one I don't like that
particular setup because I think it's a
little bit
difficult to uh to argue with I like
this one good guy
this is the setup of Achilles versus The
Tortoise you might know it better as
a person and the argument once again is
very very similar to the first one it's
that you know the story of the towards
the hair right the hair falls asleep
with a start line of course get the Head
Start now the hair is going to try and
catch up and Zeno's Paradox says that
that hair can never ever catch that
Taurus
and here's why at any given point in
time the tortoise is somewhere
all right and so the hair has to from
wherever he wakes up
track down that chorus so it has to get
to the spot where the Taurus was at but
in the time that it took that hair to
get there the tortoise has advanced not
very quickly because it's a tortoise but
the Taurus doesn't look forward
so now
the air has to uh or Achilles in this
case has to cross the distance that the
uh that the Taurus will do the Indian
trip and while he does that the Taurus
has moved again and again and again and
this repeats add infinitum and the
argument here that xenom I made is
there's no way for Achilles to ever
staff reports because every time he
makes up the distance to Taurus
it's a silly sounding Paradox but it's a
topic I'm going to I'm going to return
to numerous times through this talk
because I think it's a great analogy for
what it is we're doing now I don't want
to handle this too much to death because
this is a talk where reducibility not
as you know his analogy so let's move on
and tell
us all right now our story like all good
stories starts with a big event it
starts with failure
okay it's starting with a workshop that
we ran at the type Institute
at Toyota Institute we uh we called a
number of our colleagues in and we were
doing a workshop on I think it was
texting
texting which meant we had a bunch of
researchers come in and we worked on
these problems for a couple of weeks
came up with some great results
um celebrated our results wrote them all
up shared them amongst each other's
patted each other on the back and went
home very successful inventor so we
thought until two months later when we
came back and tried to extend those
results
and that's when we noticed something we
noticed that the uh the data the results
that we had
didn't look right we were trying to
embed text I think we're doing a glove
embeddings of a text quarters or
something and the dimensions of the data
set were wrong just plain raw which
means somewhere along the way we subset
it or sub-sampled the data
but we hadn't written down anything
about how we've done that we had the
analysis but we didn't know how we got
that data set and that's the problem
because then we can't line anything up
so we had to throw that analysis away
now it's at the end of the world it's a
minor failure we just have to do the
work again but it was still a little bit
frustrating and so if God is thinking
you know I really wish there was
something that we could do to improve
the reproducibility of our data science
workflows at the pet Institute
now
and as serendipitous piece of uh a
coincidence later that month I found
myself into it at high Khan
and that year if I thought there was a
tutorial called down the rabbit hole 101
on reproducible workflows with python
and I thought hey I just had this
problem I'm gonna go and take this
tutorials it was a really really nice
tutorial uh and in fact it introduced me
to something which hopefully many of you
have already seen is something called a
cookie cutter cookie cutter data science
the particular is this thing now cookie
cutter if you're not familiar with it
it's just a templating system for
starting a python project so rather than
going and copying The Notebook it kind
of look something like what you want to
do emptying the text out and pasting new
stuff in you can fire a cookie cutter
and have it build the environment for
you possibly who do you got a data
scientist is a template that
standardizes a lot of the arbitrary
decisions that you might make
I'm starting up
now I don't know if there's anybody in
this room who has worked on uh cookie
cutter data science anybody from
kubernetes if there is come and talk to
me afterwards because we've got so much
to talk about I love the thing but I've
also got challenges that I really really
want to take you to where how we can go
ahead and uh and make progress in that
so
um
we had our challenges with our Workshop
we've gone to pycon learned about sort
of all the the nice ways that we can do
reproducibility we found this great
template that was kind of an empty
template but we had our own workflows we
thought hey this is a great opportunity
for us to take our existing data science
workflows and build them into this
template and build a nice reproducible
pipeline clients everybody's dream right
build a nice reproducible pipeline where
everything you do just magically works
the second time you do it
um we did we spent the rest of the year
doing that and we came down here in
November and actually presented this as
a tutorial tutorial was called up your
bus number
all right and that sounds sorry that
sounds a bit like a Scottish relative
cursing a good boss number but that's
not what I that's all what I mean what I
meant by that was bus number that's the
number of people that have to get hit by
a bus before you're okay the science
workflow is not reproducible anymore in
our case when we started our bus number
was Zero hopefully yours is a bit better
than that but the whole point is by
introducing reproducibility into your
workflows you can make that better you
can keep some of that institutional
knowledge around
um in your organization so we came down
here to New York City and we presented
this tutorial and it went
okay
it went okay because we came in with
what I think is the wrong goal we came
in the goal of getting people from the
start line of their data science
analysis to the finish line of their
data science science analysis in a way
that would be reproducible
but this is where Xeno popes up his ugly
head has anybody here participated in a
tutorial here or at any of these other
events uh python related events all
right there's a little bit of xenos
paradox going on here how come this is
always something you like say V standing
at the front of the room you have a good
tutorial and when you get to a certain
spot in that tutorial and now it's your
job to catch up
and while you're catching up to that
Squad tutorial I'm going ahead and
teaching you more stuff which means that
you still got to catch up a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and all the time if anything
goes wrong you're just pushing over to
the fence and hoping you're gonna have
time to fix it later
you're pushing all that hard stuff in
the end and go figure not everybody
makes it to the end without tutorial
hey you're always getting halfway to
halfway to halfway to where the guy at
the front of them
that's kind of what we expected we've
got a bunch of these this is kind of the
thing that we expected
we gave this tutorial but what actually
happened was a little bit different
all right we came into this tutorial
thinking about the start line for
reproducible data science was up there
that we'd start with data sets we
download some raw data off the internet
do some processing of that do an
analysis and then publish result and
that's a reproducible data science
workflow
but in fact a lot of people that came to
our tutorial and had difficulty with
what was going on didn't even make it to
that start line
they encounter challenges somewhere
before that in the data science process
it may have been challenges for getting
the data to to be in the right spot on
our on our laptop might have been a
challenge in building that content
environment in the first place it might
have been a challenge with getting the
right tools installed to actually run
the conduct commands it might have been
uh just getting anything to work on
their laptop at all the fact of the
matter was is we were wrong about where
the start line for reproducible data
science really was
and so that gave us a moment of Revenue
we thought we were there but in fact
reproducibility this data science starts
a whole heck of a lot sooner and that
was an important insight
the insight for us was that data science
reproducibly is not about getting from
the start line of the finish line
it's about taking your collection of
data scientists and getting them all to
the start line together
get them all to the same place so that
they can run the same things and then if
only that through all the other kinds of
reproducibility you can follow on if you
can't do that if you can't ever get
everybody to start the same place and be
able to run these these pieces of code
in the first place you're dead in the
water
that's when our journey really began
that's when if you're following this as
a the hero's journey of the story I'm
telling now that's when we cross the
threshold in to something new and that's
when we changed our approach to how we
were doing reproducibility so we ran
this tutorial here in New York
we learned a lot it was a moderate
success but an excellent learning
opportunity
we're really impressed by this we're
really impressed by the fact that we
actually managed to learn more about
reproducibility I would say in that 90
minutes here in this room than we did in
the six months it was taking us before
that to develop this in our own shop and
we thought hey there's something that we
can get out of this there's something
that we should take away from this Pi
data experience and that is we should
run more workshops we should run
workshops internally so that we can
get these learnings so that we can get
this information quickly see how real
people respond to our workflows and then
see what they're going to do
so that was our approach we said hey
organization we would like to help you
run more workshops more Springs more
data stuff and the pandemic really
helped us out here too
because we all got sent home and we had
to work remotely and one of the things
our organization learned during the
pandemic is it was a lot easier to make
progress on a problem if you got people
organized around some kind of event some
kind of Sprint some kind of focusing
activity so that their attention didn't
wander and go someplace else and so our
organization started running a lot of
these focused Workshop events
so basically people in our organization
would approach us with a talk
and we would help them set up the
infrastructure to run their event
all right we would act as a help desk
during the event uh whenever people had
issues getting their chronic
environments to build we'd help them out
figure out what that is and at the end
of the workshop we take all those
outputs take all those uh those products
that came out of this and we'd make an
exhaustive list of all of the ways that
reproducibility failed during the event
um we take that list and we pull it back
we'd say is there a way for us to attack
some of these problems at a fundamental
level
so the rest of this talk at least the
minute part of this talk was going to be
some of the lessons that we learned some
of those big ideas that we took away
from these large reproducibility fields
from doing these workshops over and over
and over changing things as we went
experimenting trying a new uh new
flavors of our uh of our uh of our
framework uh and then deploy it again
for the next one
and so I'm going to give you a series of
lessons to learn six Lessons Learned
over that process but before I do I just
want to give another half
anybody in the room who hasn't been
involved in a project called Headroom
I really wish there is if you've been
involved in Canada or if you know the
origin story of Pedro if you can put me
in touch with the people who know you
were in the story of Pedro please do so
because working with Pedro was kind of a
weird kind of dark mirror or an
alternate universe experience for me I
felt like Doctor Strange was going to
walk out of the wall with a zombie
version of me and say shell you're
breaking the Multiverse because Kendra
and easy data our framework use exactly
the same language to describe the
problem they're attacking September one
way to solve the tip of that Pyramid
open up and easy data went the other way
to solve the base of that pyramid it's
like they're
in a pod that somehow got separated I'd
really like to know what the rest of
that organ story is so
if you know anybody involved in that
come talk to me afterwards I would
definitely love to find everyone
all right
so let's move on to Lessons Learned now
this isn't going to be a particularly
technical talk I'm not going to get into
details uh although I'm happy to answer
questions about these types of things
because I've given technical talks on
this topic before in fact if you go and
look up videos from Pioneer Global uh
this past year you're going to find two
talks given by Williams one of those
waiting for me the other way with my
wife
um I was giving a technical talk on sort
of some of the lessons that were learned
here and she was giving a tutorial on
how to use the infrastructure or the
framework the easy data
so go and check those things out if you
want some more details
lesson one on using give
of course is a revision because how many
people here use it in their data science
workloads now that is excellent all
right using risk because they gave rate
idea for helping to capture some of the
history around what's going on you're
changing stuff you're capturing that
history it's wonderful but it comes with
challenges the first challenge is git
isn't so much a tool as a kitchen drawer
filled with sharp but potentially useful
objects
okay it is a tool kit that can
occasionally shoot you or stab you in
this case in the foot by the way most of
these pictures are generated by like AI
things to disable the fusion I also
threat kitchen Drum Corps a jump core
single infusions a very angry system
it really should sharpen point but that
did remind me of
the games okay so git can be difficult
so when you are structuring your
workloads around using git as a
repository there's a few things that
you've got to keep in mind to keep from
getting yourself
into trouble
and the first is that get into the
structure around text
I think it is good at versioning text
technically it converges anything but it
doesn't give you much useful information
about what changes so anything that you
do in your data size workflow that you
won't get to help you with has not been
a nice text based format well that's
awesome thank you but two that
text-based format usually has to be
human readable too
and the reason is when things go wrong
in case you have multiple people using
that get a repository you're going to
find you're gonna have to resolve
conflicts and it will resolve conflicts
you kind of got to figure out what's
going on and just because your data
serialization format can help it to
something which is text like does not
mean it's necessarily going to help you
with that process
so one example I can think of of a
format which is technically text but not
particularly useful when stuffing git
Jupiter notebook
there are more than a few challenges to
try and get Jupiter notebooks to work
nicely with you this is a hard problem
lots of people have done some good
thinking about it but it's something
that you want to think carefully about
when you're using it as the main state
of your version control the final thing
I want to say about it is you've got to
be careful when you get into a
multi-user environment as I mentioned
easy data was sort of built to do
workshops workshops you have a lot of
people working in a game free Pub
one of the worst things you can do and
to get repo with lots of people working
on it is have large files with lots of
little bits in them say giant Json
objects with a whole bunch of different
little pieces all in a single file
because as soon as two people touch
different parts of that file you
potentially got conflicts there's all
sorts of little things change
and you don't want that it works best
when you when you respect the fact that
you want to keep
files as localized as possible so try
not to for instance serialize your data
format says something which is one giant
file with a bunch of Json sections in it
maybe serialize it to a directory full
of individual Json options now we have
one person working on this part of the
problem and another person's working on
the other they're not going to get those
kids a lot of work that we did was just
coming up with new serialization formats
for things that we were doing that
respected this this property
one more thing about yet the ultimate
downside of it is that when you're using
it you
how to use it effectively anytime you
incorporate git into a workflow and try
and standardize on it you're going to
find yourself teaching a lot
get tutorials and developing a lot of
onboarding materials and that is okay
that is in fact a necessary part of this
process so by all means use git use
getting your teams just make sure you
incorporate tutorial buildings and
onboarding
yes if you use our framework there is a
bunch of that stuff built in which is
nice to have but you're likely going to
have
Europe okay so great you're all on board
believe me now you're happy to all use
git with all of those sharp pointy uh
warning that is given
what's next use Virtual programs how
many people here use Virtual
environments uh for doing your python
work excellent virtual environments are
wonderful they're really the only way to
get things done because everybody knows
the system python any computer just
doesn't work uh and it's not gonna work
it's not going to run the stuff that you
need to run anyway so you're going to
have to use a virtual environment some
way
which virtual environment do you use
let's pass now that depends on a lot of
things I'm going to make an assumption
for the rest of this talk I'm going to
say conduct sort of
um condo with workarounds kind of end
with workarounds
um but that's because that works for me
the thing about virtual environment
managers is each and every one of those
is great in its own way each and every
one of those solves 80 of the virtual uh
environment problem
but each and every one of those cells
are different
and that's okay because all of us have
different challenges so depending on
what your needs are you're going to end
up in a different bubble in here you
have to build a slightly different
workflow that makes use of virtual
environments like this I do a lot of
work not just with condo packages but
also with pit packages so I got to be
able to mix those also I have
dependencies which are not necessarily
true or python which means I really need
to get into that quantity space and also
I want to serialize the whole thing to a
git repo that I've done which means I
really want to start using content and
on top of all that
but then I want a whole bunch of other
things to work online workrooms so use
the virtual environment manager of your
choice but use the one that makes sense
for you
and this one and this is a battle I this
is a hill I am willing to die on
um but this is a battle I have to fight
just about every day within our teams
and it is this if you're going to use a
virtual environment please do not use a
single monolithic environment please do
not do a Content activate data science
I'm not going to ask you to raise your
hands for how many of you assume that on
a regular basis what I'm going to ask
you to do is try and split apart your
virtual environments in my case whenever
I have a get repo I create a virtual
environment with exactly the same name
so I have only one virtual environment
per data science repo and the reason I
do that is because if I have a
monolithic environment
chances are I'm going to have to go and
add something to that environment as I
go whenever I add something things tend
to get a little dicey sometimes and you
have to troubleshoot that and you have
to try and fix that how many of you have
ever done this combat uh conda install
package failure okay you can hang it
just sits there for half an hour and
does nothing
it would install package success
right
do you think the people actually
installed all those dependencies
correctly you think it's that much
smarter no what probably happened is one
of those advantages just got ignored
because it had to because it was the
only way to resolve the problem but what
you've probably done in that scenario is
silently broken something now it's
probably not the project you're working
on because you'll notice that right away
you've probably silently broken
something that used to work in this
content environment another one of the
projects that you work on and that's a
reproducibility problem that you're
going to find later and you're going to
have no idea what caused that bridge so
don't do it don't use monolithic virtual
environments
it was block files this is tough this is
not it doesn't do this how many people
here use lock files along with their
virtual environments that's great the
rest of you are saying what is a lock
file shop
cool what I mean by lock file is this I
want you to separate your
environment specifications into two
pieces
all right I want you to have one of them
that says what are the things that I
want in this environment
and the other one is saying what are the
things that I actually needed to install
to make this environment work
because practically speaking to new
reproducible data science we need both
of those things
why do we both do those things well
there comes a point in time where you
just want that notebook that used to
work six months ago to work again even
though the universe has moved on
dependencies have moved on condo Forge
has moved on and nothing works with
itself anymore
you need to be able to step back in time
by note exactly what was installed to
make that notebook work and reinstall it
that's what a log file is a log file
locks all the dependencies and keep
track of them absolutely everything that
got installed all 500 packages when you
said conda install pandas
now the other thing you want to keep
track of is what are the packages you
really wanted what are the things that
you really need in this environment well
it has and that's it
that's important because later on if you
want to install something else
you're going to need to build a new
environment and if you use everything
that got installed when you said you
can't install whatever that old package
was
it might not work
you're not
needing all those other factors you're
needing whatever it is that makes pandas
work you're going to need whatever it is
that makes eye graph work you're needing
whatever it is to make that set of
things that you desperately need to do
your analysis work and you don't care
what the other stuff is
so when you want to move forward you
need the what you want file and when you
want to go back and make something work
like it used to you need to what you
actually don't file that's why you want
to use block files with your virtual
events
and then
using git you want to check those
virtual environments into your git repo
you don't want to be dropping the
command line and pip install and stuff
because you're not going to know that
after the phone
so you're going to want to make sure
that any changes that you make to your
environment get checked
all right
in terms of lock files what we do is we
use a very very very very
hot tub process that uses an
environmental file environment yaml is
the file that we use to specify what we
want
okay what we want is a particular
version of python not that one much
newer Griffin what we want is a
particular set of conduct packages what
we want is a particular set of okay
installable packages uh and what we want
is a particular set of channels in a
particular order to make sure that this
build is actually going to work that's
our what you want file and then we use
some make file magic to generate our log
fun
now baseball magic sounds like some kind
of hack some kind of brutal terrible
hack that just happens to work for Shell
along with anybody else that's probably
but there are other projects of the
world that do this too
another one of those projects that does
it is condo lock anybody here use condo
lock
it's a pretty cool project that I really
really wish I could use anybody here
knows anybody involved this project get
them to get hold of me because I want to
talk I want I want to figure out a way
to make our workarounds work with their
workarounds but kind of law basically is
intended to solve all these problems
it's intended to separate the what you
want from what you've got keep track of
all those things so you could either go
back in time and make stuff work or add
stuff to your environment and still have
to work it's a really neat project and
it's almost where it needs to be to
solve all of my problems
okay we're using it we're using virtual
environments we're splitting things into
what I want and what I actually need
next thing you need to do is script your
workflow
okay
what do I mean by workflow
workflow
is the set of tools that you use to do
data science plus all the icky
workarounds that you use to make those
tools work I claim that a workflow is
almost always going to evolve both of
those things
and the reason you want to script your
workflow and not just your set of tools
is because I will occasionally change my
mind about what tools can do the job in
this talk alone I said hey I had a
manual process for doing my log files
but hey there's this great project
called condoloc which if they solve my
one remaining problem tomorrow I'm going
to start using
but I don't want to have to retrain
every data scientist in my group on how
we're doing our data science tomorrow
every time we make a total state because
this space in data science moves way too
fast the reason I come here is just to
barely hang on about all the new stuff
that's what I get to learn at Pi data
but I don't want to have to go back and
retrain everybody in our organization
how to use the new tools so what we do
is we script the workflow and for us
remember all I'm talking about your
reproducibility is getting everybody to
the same start line that workflow is
basically building that environment that
everybody's going to use
them so workflow basically looks like
this regardless of how it's Implement
membership regardless of which tool
choices we use on
we do a make-grade environment to create
that virtual environment in the first
place we activate that new environment
by whatever mechanism you activate your
environments and then when we make
changes to it as we go we go make up a
department
if ever anything goes wrong
make noise environment it sounds like we
could do any of those steps manually but
I highly encourage you not to because
inevitably if you've got workarounds
there's steps you can miss when you
start doing things manually don't
conda and Mamba are both absolutely
amazing tools and they come really close
to what I need to do this workflow in a
reproducible way but they're not quite
there there are some critical critical
bugs to give both when it comes to
dealing with multiple channels when I
have stuff from Anaconda proper and I
have stuff from condo Forge try to make
those two things work together requires
being very specific about which channel
is done when
a main problem inside conda and mobile
right now that we've found is that
channel information is lost as soon as
you build that
anywhere which means if you don't keep
enough information around outside of the
usual conduct channels you can't
recreate or add anything to that
generated environment it just won't work
this is a hairy bug it's crazy but it
bites us all the time in our data
science
so
by years involved in the maintenance or
writing of any of these utilities come
and talk to me afterwards I best I've
got some great ideas
all right
almost there four up six lesson number
four is eliminate hidden State this is
actually reproducibility in a nutshell
right here anytime that you've got any
kind of hidden State any state which is
not serialized in your gate repo or in
your Version Control mechanism you have
got a potential reproducibility feeling
tricky part is finding all that in the
state I mean one example is just drop
into the command line of hip installing
a module if you don't record the fact
that that module is part of your
environment somewhere that's hidden
state
another piece of
very very difficult to troubleshoot hit
the state
is the pipe python modules that are on
your say laptop before you even start
the building environment
that's going to affect what conda mamba
or any other the virtual backup managers
download
and that state is not recorded anywhere
unless you go out of your way to record
it so finding and eliminating in the
state is kind of the main figure but how
do you do it I'm going to give you the
two tips that have gotten us
obviously three times get everything you
can that just makes sense right that's
that's how you're going to get rid of it
in the state
um the first tip I'm going to give you
is this one develop amnesia
okay because if you do anything that
relies on your memory when you sit down
at a keyboard that's hidden State okay
so if you can train yourself out of
remembering anything of always having to
look into your git repo for where you
were last time and what you were doing
you're going to get really good at
getting that hit the state out of there
would anybody like tip on how to develop
ambition
you can do what I did have two young
children
it works every time I sit down on the
keyboard it is amazing I have given me
the magical ability to find hidden state
in just about every one of my workload
there may be other ways to do it too but
I recommend small children
scissors dark cute
the other thing uh the other test that I
used on a regular basis for determining
whether I have found all the hidden
state in my data science repositories is
the old Aliens new guitar
am I willing at any given time to take
off and nuke the whole cycle Market am I
willing to delete my entire working
directory my repository whatever it is
check it back out and build it from
scratch am I willing to type delete
environment
because if I'm not or if I've got any
lingering fear about that lingering fear
is telling me that I have forgotten to
check something in I have forgotten to
capture some state
if you get to the point where you are
confident that you're not going to lose
anything when you do make delete
environment come a long way towards
eliminating that human statement so do
that check wait am I going to delete
this no I better check something in
and this new this is my new yearbook
process in fact in some make files I
have scripted this nuked it from orbit
all it does is deletes everything and
then recreates the environment
now I said
eliminating a hidden state is important
and I said in almost every case you want
to get that hidden State into your get
repo and I'm going to say asterisk
except in a couple of important cases
there are certain pieces of information
local configuration information in
particular that you never ever want to
end up in your git repo because it will
cause reproducibility fail
or it'll cause all your passwords and
credentials to be exposed and that's
another issue that will be familiar with
other kinds
you probably don't want
um so local state is something you want
to keep algorithm
as an example of local state well one
it's a colossal usability almost every
notebook I get handed from a colleague
starts with a line like this here's my
file name home bestboy clients Elon
reach at kill file and then load some
data from that place
right why is this a problem well
obviously reproducibility failed because
I don't have any of those paths on my
system I mean whitening yes yes so like
you know that's that's not a thing
that's going to work for me
you're just like it was second and
possibly more importantly if you have
actual Appliance up there
perhaps can lead to all sorts of
information they can link your username
they can link your client names they can
leave stuff about the client data that
you don't necessarily want getting in
the wild let alone getting checked into
your history
so one of the things you're going to
want to do is come up with mechanisms
and come up with with uh with workflows
that get rid of hard-coded like this an
easy data we do it like this we have a
mechanism called paths we just import it
from The Source module
um and we have a bunch of standard
locations and they have default
locations but the point is they don't
have to by the way from Python's
perspective this just looks like a
dictionary dictionary it looks like I
got a dictionary called path where I
keep all the paths under the hood it's
not actually that under the hood it's a
little more clever than that in that it
is a file serialized disk
okay and so sending a member of this
dictionary serializes the disk even
better it's all relative paths to things
right you don't really have to specify
one thing and that's where like any one
of these names is and then everything
else could be relative to it
and so we use the location of this
catalog file this configurative file as
the place to make everything else
relevant
so this is the set of defaults but you
can change this to point anywhere in
your system
all right and you should on your local
system if you keep big data on a
different map Point somewhere by all
means point one of these things
now but the special thing about this
particular file is if you look in my git
repo it is never ever checked in to get
my ignore file says never check that
file in always use it always have it
never check it in I think it doesn't
check in there's a little Falcon anybody
here use dot m the python module called
dot end it is a way to handle secrets
that keeps the secrets out of your
notebooks which is a really good thing
to do and into a file called dot end now
if you go and accidentally commit that
thing and you're gonna repo you have
undone all the work of getting out of
your notebooks so don't do that make
sure you keep it in a centralized
location but out of gate make sure you
got to get ignore file make some local
data out
all right the reason gets we're using
virtual environments we're scripting our
workflows we're getting rid of hidden
state but we're leaving that local stuff
where it belongs locally and not
checking that in but the last thing we
have to do to get everybody to that
common start line to get everybody
re-producibly to the same spot so they
can start their data science analyzes we
have to leave ourselves through
breadcrumbs whenever possible if you're
building templates and workflows for
your your data science work leave
yourself hints about where to go next
some of these are really stupid some of
these are really easy
one such convention that we use is
number your notebooks we brought this
from cookie cutter data science right
number your notebooks one two three out
of the words you want after that doesn't
matter but the point is when you sit
down you know what order you got to run
those notebooks in
silly little tweak but it's a breadcrumb
it gives you a hint of where you want to
go next all right another thing that we
do
our makeup we used to make both script
everything I never remember what the
targets are in my make file my all sorts
of things we use a self-documented trick
that we also start with
um that lets us every time we create a
new Target of that make file it just
steals the comment from right before
that Target and use it to create this
beautiful documentation
so whenever somebody comes to me asks
what's that command that I got to use to
do that I say type mate
it'll tell you and there you go
I mean this is the idea I still can get
if you use get regularly get status
almost always tells you the right
command to type next the most amazing
help message I have ever seen so
whenever possible in your workflows make
sure that you leave yourself
so we talked a fair bit about your
critical data science here's my final
question let me know when you're done
in our case we have to set ourselves a
concrete role and it was this we don't
know we are done with our definition of
reproducibility when our users can check
out that that git repo full of our data
science uh for our data science workshop
and get up and running with that first
notebook within 15 minutes that's
everything that's environment creation
download the data whatever it happens to
be they're up and running in 15 minutes
the reason I'm here this year to
presents not just because the pandemic's
over and I love seeing people in person
it's also because we finally when we ran
an event last February hit our Target
almost every one of our users is able to
get up and running uh this workflow
Within
and what were the holy Grails what were
the secrets to getting this
reproducibility into our workflow
this is getting our users to a common
start line it was building all that
infrastructure that wasn't even on our
radar when we started
all right but get into that common start
line we give them a set of conventions
and breadcrumbs to tell them where to go
next we eliminate all the hidden seat
get the stuff checked in there through a
combination of Amnesia and fear
or tell them how to do
a data size part of the jobs because you
know what as data scientists that's the
part we all like
the part we don't like is all this stuff
so this is the part that we automate for
and we let data scientists do what data
scientists are going to do which is good
notebooks full of reproducible and
delicious data science work
PostScript I did open this talk with
xenos Paradox well guess what
I've solved xenos Paradox I know the
solution and the solution is pretty
simple you just got to be super
ambitious if you're worried about xeno's
Paradox clients would say Ottawa to New
York City you're worried about getting
stuck halfway don't book a ticket to New
York City book one to Miami
that way when you get diverted to New
York not a problem it's packs are right
away
same thing goes for data science if you
want to solve your reproducibility we'll
always aim high try and solve everything
that's what we did we started at the tip
of that pyramid and we slid all the way
back to largely solving a workflow but
the good news is we just declared that
line in the middle of that halfway line
to be our Finish Line
that's how you saw this paradox
and that's the time thank you very much
for your attention